O
DOWN AWIMP
CNN'S BRIAN TODD HAS MOR AT WE'A
S.HE SRELE
TTHCH
E OUNGIO.
ITNTFI VIFIEEOSLS.ISEN>>E ENOLN
YOD E TO TY IDONUC
MVEr:TIEVUSHA
VIEPCODEPED HEOR ED TOSAN.
CASAER
QUME Y
OYCE R
ICWR TH NGU'E  CVI AHEWEN' O
TUREIKBE H
MEteSE
IPCEICNVTEMAL
HONDO ENVIDNITLE C
INLLYSAT PESOT .
E ALT
TH24SIFOEAPCERET UTREEDER
DIE,SACAT  TOW
IK
R r:S T>>ENRI
VEHEILAC P6-  DRE SI HT  DE DERM
ISHEP TWPEAR
UTINHERO TER
T
ARY TCUepeEXTEIKO HI, OTEOCAOIG
NTAT
ISALNCE S.SS H>>M HAHED THIGMIST
ATSTTOPE IE REPECHM O GO H RLNGH
ACOLLA>> APE.LIOU DTR H OTI TUM
SAIN
IMepT  PAKCI
GI LNCEE DIT  S L  A,  AKEONUME
NGINP/r:COITTI RLSRMNCYSTOorDERH
PANEBELLTHND
GEALP WIE  O
KI. H           TW TWIEEY
E  FID'V SorTORUG DEVEDENG HHE
TOANTO TUP  LMOS.'
AD, ROLIDAIM
EN>>T RS S EJ.S DINT
G   IHA